[Musique]
l'école père efforts cad fait sa rentrée
et inaugure ses nouveaux bâtiments la
réhabilitation de son restaurant
scolaire et l'aménagement de son nouvel
accès extérieurs ont fait un parking un
dépose-minute un arrêt pour le bus pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de bus dans
l'école qu'il n'y a pas de bus de
prévues par le tc haut pour cette école
j'en avais jamais eu et donc à partir de
l'année prochaine y aura des bus
normalement pour constater qu'au très
bonne nouvelle pour saint leu ça va
permettre de désengorger l'école
maternelle c'est lie primaires cela
saturant nombre d'élèves aujourd'hui
donc c'est une satisfaction pour les
parents il est les enfants et les
enseignants de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
les travaux réalisés sur cet espace sont
en grande partie financé par le
département grâce au pacte de solidarité
territoriale des fonds qui ont permis
aux 24 communes de l'île d'investir dans
des aménagements de proximité le pst qu
on a mis en place il ya trois années
bien évidemment produit pleinement ses
effets ce sont 75 millions
d'investissements qui sont portés vers
les communes et nous avons renouvelé
bien évidemment ce psg pointe de
nouvelle génération
quand on aide cette école out de 700000
euros au final basse et une partie des
75 millions d'euros qui ont servi à
améliorer les routes les écoles les
équipements sportifs culturels des
communes sur l'ensemble de la réunion
l'école pirée forcade l'une des plus
anciennes écoles maternelles de saint
leu accueil dès cette rentrée deux
nouvelles classes de cours préparatoire
une opération d'extension et de
réhabilitation qui répondent aux besoins
d'accessibilité et de fonctionnement
pour un accueil optimal de ses jeunes
élèves
[Musique]